I received a call from Rob Marshall and
he left a very ceremonious what charged
voicemail on my phone saying I had to
call him I was like oh god what is it
and he pitched me the idea of doing a
sequel to Mary Poppins and they wanted
to do it with me so I was blown away by
the whole idea of it
MARY POPPINS was what opened my mind up
in the world up to movies and magic and
music so doing a sequel to Mary Poppins
you know the first thing you think is
gulp but then you realize that there
were eight books altogether there was a
real sense that there's so much more
story to be told it's really exciting I
mean the chance to explore that world
even more in this new original story
with incredible enchanting original
music to what it was pretty clear there
was no one else that could play this
role as brilliantly as Emily Blunt
well brings you here after all this time
the same thing that brought me the first
time I've come to look after the banks
children ah oh yes you too
it's so wonderful the soul of the movie
it's about the power of the imagination
it was a real sense that we're part of
something very special
we all cared so deeply about the project
because this is a film with great hope
and spectacle and it's moving so I think
it's a very important film to be making
right now
are we ready ready
[Music]